for this lesson you'll be focusing on
practicing Dom manipulation methods
you'll start by accessing data about
existing notes and modifying that data
you'll finish by adding and removing Dom
elements I won't be covering all of
jquery's methods but most of them follow
pretty much the same pattern and after
these examples you won't have any
problem
tackling additional methods this is the
jQuery API documentation on the left you
can see the main types of jQuery methods
I want to start by modifying the class
attribute so I'll click on attributes I
can see a few methods I'll go ahead and
start with add class which does pretty
much exactly what you think it does it
adds a specified class to a Dom element
this black box shows the main function
signature which tells you what to pass
in as an argument to this method to get
it to work properly this description is
pretty useful it looks like this method
takes in a string of a class name and
adds it to selected elements so if I
passed in blue to this method
I'd add the blue class to the element
with the ID of item inside the black box
you can find different ways of using the
method including this one where you can
pass a function to add class huh well
that seems kind of weird if I read
further though we see that this function
must return a string it could be a
string of a single class name or it
could be many class names separated by
spaces and then below we have some
in-depth discussion and some examples
that's pretty cool in other examples
like dot parents for instance you'll see
parameters inside square brackets the
square brackets mean that the parameter
is optional and the method will work
just fine with or without it now that
I've walked you through the
documentation I want you to try parsing
some documentation for yourself you're
going to start by modifying some data in
the DOM